[Music]
let's talk about this YouTube
documentary because it's gonna follow
your journey in making this new album
yes what do you want people and viewers
to take away I want them to see my
journey I want them to learn about my
life today rather than thinking about my
life in the past you know a lot of
people have heard my story I've been
very open about it but a lot of people
don't know what my life is like today
and I get to share that with my fans
which is so important to me I also get
to share the making of the album my
music is more soulful this time around
you also get to see some of my phone
throughout that work so but you get to
learn about my life my family and my
friends and it's just honestly it's just
an opportunity to bring my fans closer
to me how would you describe your life
and yourself today my life is the title
of the documentary which is simply
complicated then you'll understand why
when you watch the documentary you said
more soulful are we gonna hear more
collaborations I haven't put together
many collaborations yet there will be we
just have to figure out where they go
but my music will be more R&B more
soulful and you'll just have to wait and
hear the rest you posted a picture with
javi recently yeah is that a possible
collaboration I would love to do
something with holes
you tweeted the other day that there's a
song on there that you're nervous yeah
for fans to hear why are you nervous I'm
just nervous because fans read into
everything and I know that they're gonna
read into it and it just makes me
nervous
lyric wise yes anything else that you
can tell us like a release date um very
soon as all I can really say so fingers
crossed that it's sooner than you think
yeah will you be touring the album yes I
will I'm sure I'll be touring next year
I spy a music video for sorry not sorry
it was so much talk to me about that
song and the message that you wanted to
convey the message in that song is for
the haterz you know it's I actually a
lot of people think that it's about like
a relationship and it could be for other
people but for me it was I had never
written a song about the bullying that I
experienced when I was in Middle School
and it drove me out of public school and
I started homeschooling because it got
so bad it was just a feel-good song and
I came in with the concept and then we
wrote to it and it turned out to be more
so about the haters rather than an X
which was which was cool and I think it
makes it more relatable for people to
relate to
[Music]
you